juste par curiosité pourquoi ce garçon à quoi ça
sert pourquoi tu
aimes prendre des innocents et
trouver un moyen de faire en sorte que les hommes ne vont pas bien
vous ce déjeuner, mettez du lait sur moi et
mettez la main sur mes vêtements est-ce qu'ils
ne l'ont pas fait avant que ce ne soit
différent n'a pas besoin d'être critiqué
à ce sujet hé ce n'est pas de leur faute mais si
vous êtes compagnon inscrivez-vous juste oh don  ne laissez pas
cela vous déranger, vous vous
améliorerez probablement, n'est-ce pas
[Musique]
le fait qu'il ait toujours de la sympathie
et de la compassion pour les autres quand
il le traverse lui-même
témoigne de qui il est et ce gamin
est toujours un  la légende va le voir il
s'appelle Keaton